I think the media today is the temple
mess.
I mean,
it's all sound bytes.
It's all sex.
It's all confrontation.
It's all absurd.
Phony reality shows high.
It's very hard to have an intelligent
discourse that loss any amount of time
where someone can actually ask
questions,
you can answer them,
they can ask a followup question,
you can answer.
You can actually get the brain opening
and closing and moving around and
digesting this material and dwelling on
it.
It's all,
what can you say?
And five words,
you know,
how can you sum this up?
So at Peta,
we have become gimmicky.
We have become sex obsessed ourselves.
You know,
we use naked women.
We use scantily close people.
Um,
we do whatever we need to do to take
this serious message and try to get it
into the media mind.
And that's very,
very hard these days because the old
days of the serious
debate.